[Music]
hey you guys I'm Katie Kraus and I'm
Dietrich Eckart and I think it's fair to
say that 2016 was filled with all sorts
of magical enchanting incredibly
impressive fashions especially on the
red carpet yeah all of those adjectives
and more Katie and I are here to run
down our favorite looks of 2016 we broke
it down into categories we are going to
start with movie premieres both long and
short dresses yes our long dress winner
is Rachel McAdams
I'm gushing about it obviously check her
out in this Elie Saab dress at the
doctor Springs premiere in London she
looked incredible
ethereal deburred detailing this was a
dress like I've never seen before but on
the other end of the spectrum we have to
just applaud Blake Lively
at the gasps girl hey at the Cafe
Society premiere in New York Karolina
Herrera
Lorraine Schwartz look at those look at
this silver dress with a pink floral
pom-pom looking embellishments all over
it the hair looks good now when it comes
to award shows the Oscars is king and no
one did it better than Jennifer Garner
it is been kind of an emotional year for
her and look she took no prisoners at
the Oscars she showed up in her gorgeous
Atelier Versace gown black chic fit her
like a glove and all eyes are on her and
this was the perfect dress to just show
up and say hey I'm here I'm okay I'm
stronger to get past this and I look
amazing 200 carats of diamond yeah a
rich girl
another big award showed the Grammys
this was Taylor Swift's here at the
Grammys she showed up with her BFF
Selena Gomez and this incredible fun
fuchsia colored skirt and had the high
slit all the way up
you saw the coral band oh that was a lot
of skin for Taylor to show did you like
it I loved it it was not expected for
her I thought the color blocking was
perfectly on trend and and two thumbs up
from me and I know a lot of people
didn't like it but the reason why she's
number one for us at the Grammys is
because it's the most memorable of the
night and it got everyone talking
showstopper and of course at the Emmys
undisputed winner Kristen Bell check out
this incredible princess almost like
giving me frozen vibe right I love
Mourad I can be such a talented designer
and I wanted to do something more
whimsical and this was perfect but
here's one of my favorite award show
moments of the entire year it's kind of
a recent one it's at the American Music
Awards Selena Gomez in this red Prada
gone holy jeez she had been m.i.a for
about three months out of the spotlight
she announced that she was gonna take a
break for health purposes that was
Selena's night as for the Oscars of
fashion the Met Gala every year brings
out the best of the best but no one did
it quite like Claire Danes this girl
committed okay she was not only enough
gown it was illuminated it was lit up
she was practically a human disco ball
glow-in-the-dark
it was glow-in-the-dark Zac Posen
incredible we kind of invented our own
category for this it's best live TV look
so not necessarily red-carpet when it's
her posing on the red carpet after
dancing the Stars every single week and
that my friends is Julianne Hough who
literally slayed it consistently every
time that I tuned in weekly for Cirque
de Soleil week that powder pink dress
with a silver lining and that headpiece
it was just next-level it was and I
don't think it's easy to come out once a
week and deliver fashion excellent time
and time again and she just did it to
the ninth incredible this is bigger than
the wedding I'll tell you that the
kardashian-jenner clan is practically
synonymous with the word fashionable
these days so we couldn't just pick one
favorite moment we had to pick two so
the first one that we want to call out
is Kylie and Kourtney at the Golden
Globes afterparty
they were first of all perfectly
color-coordinated in these gorgeous
learni metallicky shimmery princess
gowns and our other favorite moment was
at the Yeezy season 3 runway show in New
York City you had lighter tones and
blush tones and some fur and some
fabulousness and some sequins it was
literally everything I've ever dreamed
of it was like an ethereal snow chic
look and what I loved is that it was
easy and balm on like it was that
collaboration at Kardashian's they know
how to put on a show you guys hmm okay
so I know that that was a lot of looks
but we want to know who you guys thought
had the best red carpet look
2016 I'm going are you ready for this
one I feel like we have to say well I
think we do at the AMA it was her moment
I have like a story behind it gives her
extra points it was really her taking
2017 by the horn she's ready
of course tweet us your favorites who
did you think look the best this year at
Katy underscore crowds at her name is
Deidre and we'll see you next year guys
[Music]
you